tomato ketchup recipes vary only
slightly as consumers expect a certain
familiar tomatoey taste this US company
produces all-natural ketchup made
entirely of certified organic
ingredients tomato paste agave nectar a
natural sweetener onion powder spices
salt and white vinegar the tomato paste
not surprisingly is the base ingredient
it arrives at the plant in huge bins
which have been vacuum packed to
preserve freshness after unsealing each
bin the factory's quality control
technician scoops a sample for testing
this is to make sure that the thickness
is just right if the sample gets the
okay
workers slide the bin under a powerful
air driven pump
then they flip a switch and the pump
begins moving the tomato paste to a
large holding tank transferring nearly
310 pounds of this ketchup base in less
than 10 minutes at production time an
intricate system of piping transfers a
specific amount of tomato paste from the
holding tank into a cooking kettle as
the paste cooks a mixer continuously
revolves to keep it from sticking to the
sides and to blend in the onion powder
workers at next this and the upcoming
ingredients have been pre measured to be
in correct proportion to the batch size
the next ingredients are salt then as a
sugar replacement nectar from the agave
plant they pour in an initial amount mix
a bit then pump in the remainder the
last ingredient is white vinegar
on the packaging line an alignment
machine stands the plastic bottles
upright as they make their way to the
filling machine the finished ketchup
meanwhile is passing through an
elaborate system of cooling pipes and
route to the filler and let the bottling
begin
the machine fills 8 bottles at a time
the factory tests every batch of ketchup
it produces to ensure the correct
consistency in every bottle the next
machine appropriately called the capper
places a plastic flip cap on each bottle
then with spinning circular belts twist
it on securely
the next machine cuts a decorative neck
band made of plastic film and slips it
over the cap then a quick blast of hot
steam shrinks the band to a tight fit
the next machine presses on two adhesive
labels one on the front of the bottle
the other on the back then it's off to
the packing and shipping area a sealed
bottle of ketchup stays fresh for at
least a year because the vinegar in it
acts as a natural preservative ketchup
also has health benefits because it's
chock full of tomatoes which are high in
lycopene a powerful antioxidant believed
to protect against many types of cancer